TINO TERESHKO:
Welcome to GA 300,
awesome new features to
help you manage BigQuery.
My name is Tino Tereshko,
and I'm a product manager
on Google BigQuery.
So BigQuery, historically,
has been a serverless data
warehouse, which kind
of means a lot of things
to a lot of folks.
But in practicality
what it means to
you is that you get
unlimited scale.
BigQuery is very easy to use.
It is automatically
self-optimizing.
There's no virtual
machine-related performance
cliffs of unexpected behaviors.
It's got a high
level of reliability
and a lot of other features.
And of course, we
recently announced
that we now have an
industry-best four nines
of availability in our SLA.
So all of these are benefits
of serverless that you
get as a BigQuery customer.
Now, folks who are on the far
end of the maturity spectrum--
at large enterprises,
multinational organizations--
they actually do want more
control, more predictability.
So over the years
we've built out
a number of features
and functionalities
that enable those organizations
to take control of BigQuery
while kind of getting the best
of BigQuery being serverless.
In fact, we kind of built
BigQuery to be for everyone.
Whether you are a startup,
whether you are a student,
you're just kind of
experimenting in your garage,
we have functionality for that.
Where you care about
simplicity, ease of use,
you want to experiment quickly.
And then, as you're growing
and you have larger scales,
you want more flexibility.
You want more efficiency.
You want more predictability.
We give you that functionality.
And again, all the way out
to the largest enterprises,
where you have potentially
exabyte-scale use cases,
you want control.
You want predictability.
You want monitoring.
You want administration.
So we are there to provide
you functionality wherever
you are on this gradient.
And actually, if you move
from the startup to growth
to large enterprises,
you can take
advantage of the
various functionalities
that we have here.
Brilliant.
So let me illustrate
this whole concept
through a fictional company.
And so, why not spruce up
the administration topic
with a little bit of cats.
So this is actually
my cat, Rascal.
He's just like any other cat.
He's got a lot of personality.
And his interests
really include naps.
He really likes being petted.
He stalks the
neighborhood quite a bit.
So that's his primary things
in life that he cares about.
So what if we used cutting-edge
technology to really figure out
what Rascal does all
day and what he thinks
and what drives him to
provide a better user
experience for Rascal.
So with that in mind,
we thought about
critical feline requirements--
so short for CFRs, really.
So, the first topic,
of course, is naps.
So what do we need to
know about Rascal's naps?
Well, we need to
know how often he
naps, where he
naps-- locations--
and actually total
nap time, which tends
to be about 20 hours a day.
The second one is Rascal
loves being petted.
But there's a certain
threshold to petting.
So we need to know, what is
the optimal number of pettings
that he can sustain?
Does he like to be
pet on the belly?
pet on the head?
That's very critical
to understand.
And finally, for
our sakes, we need
to know how likely is Rascal
to be upset if we give him
just one more pet.
That's really important to know.
And finally, the third
interest of Rascal
is, he's stalking
the neighborhood.
So we need to know the
perimeter of his patrol.
What is his territory?
And a different cat
right down the street
has a different territory.
We need to know how
often he patrols it.
And maybe we can even map
the social network of Rascal
and how he interacts
with all the other cats.
These are all really,
really critical things
to know about felines.
So to that extent, we're
introducing 23andMeow.
This is a brand new,
innovative startup.
It's internet of cats.
What 23andMeow does is it
provides smart, connected
collars for cats.
Let me explain.
So you put this
collar on your cat,
and the smart collar has
lots of different sensors
that collect telemetry
data in real time.
So there is a
geospatial capability,
so it gets location of Rascal.
There's a temperature sensor.
There's an
accelerator meter that
will tell you what's
the velocity of your cat
traveling and the acceleration.
There is also a
microphone and a camera.
So you can identify sounds and
even take video and pictures.
So all of that data gets
captured and collected
in real time, and then we
perform predictive real time
analytics on all
that information.
And so, in this
sense, we give you
a better picture of what
your cat does all day
and what are your
cat's preferences.
It's beautiful.
So let's take a look
at the tech stack.
So 23andMeow heavily
relies on BigQuery.
In fact, it's essentially
the only thing
that 23andMeow is doing.
It picked BigQuery because
it's very easy to get started.
Time to market is
critical, because there
are other similar
startups that are
trying to do the same thing.
So 23andMeow wanted
to pick technology
that's serverless, that's
easy to get going with,
and also easy to grow with.
So let's walk through
this technology stack.
So first of all,
we already talked
about how a number of
sensors are sending data
into BigQuery in real time.
That includes
geospatial sensors.
And so geospatial data
comes into BigQuery.
Point number two, this data
is ingested in real time
using BigQuery's real time APIs
to get that data into BigQuery
for immediate access.
Number three, BigQuery's
new integration
with AutoML and
the Cloud AI stack
enables us to perform
machine learning right inside
of the data warehouse,
right inside
of BigQuery, on
this real time data.
So we've developed
cat behavior models
like danger of
incremental pettings.
How about the favorite
body part to be petted on?
And actually favorite
nap-time locations.
These are all really advanced
machine learning technologies
that we've implemented here
to develop this functionality.
And number four, we have
a number of public data
sets that we include that
we enrich our data with.
So for example, weather, that
depends what your cat does,
depending what the
weather outside is.
And then we're using
materialized views,
and we're moving the
data into BI engine.
And that's number five.
And of course, new, upcoming
BI engine enhancements
allow you to run BigQuery
SQL on top of BI engine.
And number six, Locker, that
recently joined our family,
is used for dashboarding
of this data.
So this is an entire
stack that essentially
lives on top of BigQuery.
Now, if you take a look at
those things, one through six,
all those things are
essentially unique to BigQuery,
or almost unique.
Which means that you
don't need to build
a number of different
technologies
to take advantage
of all these things.
This is all integrated
right into BigQuery for you.
It's beautiful.
So we started out small, right?
We rolled out our startup.
We have a few trusted
cats that we're using.
And so we're just using
BigQuery's perpetual free tier.
If you're not familiar, you
get 10 gigabytes of storage
for free every single month.
And you get a terabyte of data
processed every single month.
And we do this perpetually,
no strings attached.
You can keep using the free
tier for as long as you want.
But now that we've kind
of expanded our offering
beyond the trusted cats,
now we have 1,000 cats
that are using our collar.
So we're growing with BigQuery.
We're on that gradient.
And so we're using BigQuery's
on-demand bytes processed
model, right?
This is a billing model
that is purely consumption.
You're only paying
for what you consume.
You pay per query.
So there's no wastage,
it's super efficient,
and there's zero
administrative overhead.
You don't have to
think about anything.
There's nothing to set up.
But if you want to kind
of manage your cost
and make sure there's no runaway
bills or anything like that,
we're leveraging cost controls.
So now we've thought
about, how do we
expand our offer to make
things more interesting.
So we introduced an additional
sensor to our cat collars
that actually measures
cat pheromones
and actually smells what
the cat smells like.
And it tracks the cat pheromone
excretions and then runs
machine learning
models to understand
what your cat is feeling
at that particular moment.
So this is called
the Emotions API,
and it's available to all of
our 23andMeow customers today.
So on the back of
the Emotions API,
23andMeow has become
really successful.
We now have a whole 1
million daily active cats.
Phenomenal success.
But now, actually, our
infrastructure costs
have started to
grow as well, right?
We're running more analytics.
We're using more CPU and RAM.
We have more dashboards.
So our leverage of
BigQuery is growing.
And so we need to start worrying
about maybe monitoring it,
maybe administering
it a little bit more.
And so the question
pops up very typically
with BigQuery customers
is, are slots right for me?
For the uninitiated, there's
two billing models on BigQuery.
There's the base process model
that most customers start out
with.
And then there's
the slots model.
And the slots model is optional.
It tends to be for
the larger customers,
and it has some
really nice benefits.
So the question is, are the
BigQuery slots right for me?
Well, in order to help
our customers figure out
if that is the
right option, we're
launching something called
BigQuery slot recommendations.
It's currently in Alpha.
So this is advanced
machine learning logic
that we will run
on your usage data,
of course, using all the
right privacy controls.
And we will tell you proactively
whether the slots model
is the right model for
you, without sacrificing
performance.
So you could
potentially save money
without sacrificing
performance, which is fantastic.
And of course, the other
pricing recommendation
that we launched kind
of helps you figure out
whether you need to use
monthly slots or annual slots.
Go use that today.
And there's a related
session called
CMT 100 that talks about that
in a little bit of a greater
depth.
So what are BigQuery slots?
It's a very frequent
question that I hear.
Well, simply, a slot is a CPU.
You can think
about it like that.
And a CPU processes your
queries, runs analytics.
So whenever you purchase a
slot, or a number of slots,
you purchase analytic
processing compute capability.
You purchased
throughput, which means
that the number of slots that
you have will either give you
faster queries or will give
you more queries to run
at the same time, or both.
You're kind of buying
a cluster of BigQuery
with BigQuery slots.
And you can buy slots today
with a per second commitment,
per month, or per year.
The per second commitment
is called flex slots.
And there's no difference
between those slots,
except for flex slots you can
cancel just after 60 seconds.
So you can use them whenever
and cancel them whenever.
But they're a little
bit more expensive.
Monthly slots, you commit
to an entire month.
So you can't cancel
them or downsize them
for the duration of a month,
but you get a little bit
of a discount on that.
And then annual is, of
course, the cheapest option,
but the least flexible.
You commit to a full
year for that capacity,
but you get a discount.
So how are queries using slots?
Let's talk about that.
So a query, really, inside of
BigQuery is the Dynamic DAG--
Directed Acyclic Graph.
What that means is it's dynamic.
What does dynamic mean?
Dynamic means that, as
the query progresses,
our query execution
plan changes.
We learn more about what
you're trying to do,
we learn more about
the data patterns,
and we decide on the fly
the best path of execution.
This is really, really
powerful and really accelerates
queries for you.
But what does the DAG part mean?
The DAG part means
that a BigQuery query
is a series of stages.
Now, they can run in parallel.
They can run serially.
There's all kinds of patterns
that we can leverage there.
And each stage is
essentially a tiny mini-query
in its own right.
And each stage has a
parallelization factor,
anywhere from one to--
I've seen billions.
Which basically
BigQuery says, I can
parallelize this particular
stage of the query
by so-and-so amount.
And it's very typical to
have this parallelization
factor in thousands.
And a slot is,
essentially, that CPU
that executes a
single parallelization
unit of a single stage.
So in this particular
picture, you
see the first stage has 10,000--
a parallelization
factor of 10,000.
That means that
BigQuery could use up
to 10,000 slots at
any point in time
to execute this particular
stage of the query.
But now, 10,000 slots
is a lot of slots.
If you have a little bit
fewer than 10,000 slots,
we will simply burn
through those slots that
are not available with time.
So let's say if
you have 500 slots.
500 slots will
execute that stage,
and then 9500 slots will
essentially queue up.
And then, as the first
500 slots free up,
they will burn through that
pent-up demand with time.
And so think of a query
as a series of stages.
And each stage consumes
any number from one
to billions of
slots, potentially.
And each stage doesn't
have to get all its slots.
It will kind of wait for
the slots to come in.
Hopefully I explained
that well for you.
Now, when you have multiple
queries running concurrently,
what happens in BigQuery?
We use this concept
called fair scheduling.
What that means is, each
query gets equal right
to the available
provision slots.
Now, if a small
query comes in, it
doesn't have to use
its equal right.
It potentially could
use only a single slot
if it's a small query.
Or on the opposite
end of the spectrum,
a query could request
millions of slots.
But they get the equal right to
the capacity that's available.
Now, I've mentioned
this before already--
if a query doesn't get
100% its request the slots,
those slots just
kind of queue up.
So, it will burn through
that pent-up capacity
as slots become available.
And the final thing
I want to mention
is, BigQuery continuously
does this recalculation.
This happens in real time.
So whenever new
queries come in, we
will redistribute slots in line.
Now, the effect here is
queries speed up or slow down
in real time, rather than
kind of cancel or anything
like that.
So let me give an example.
So here on the
right side, you'll
see that the environment
has 2,000 slots in total,
and there are four
queries running in there.
And they're fairly
large queries,
so each one is
asking for 500 slots,
for the maximum amount of slots.
So our fair schedule
will actually
give each query 500 slots.
And let's say a fifth query
comes in that's a large query,
and it needs a lot
of slots, as well.
What we're going to do
automatically, in real time,
is we're going to take 100
slots away from each of the four
queries.
We'll just pause that work--
we're not going to waste it--
and we will give it
to the fifth query.
So now we have five queries
running with 400 slots each.
What that did to the
original four queries,
it just made them a little
bit slower than before.
So the system works
really, really well.
It actually biases against
large runaway queries.
And it biases for smaller
queries that have lower latency
requirements.
So it's a very,
very useful pattern.
So BigQuery slots pricing.
Let's talk about
the benefits here.
The first one, of
course, it's predictable.
You control how much you spend.
You explicitly tell us, I want
to purchase x amount of slots
and it's going to cost me
a certain amount of money.
Now, I've mentioned
before, we have
three types of commitments.
We have monthly,
annual, and flex slots.
Monthly and annual
require you to commit
to 30 days or a full year.
And flex slots essentially
have no commitment period.
So you can purchase them and
cancel them whenever you want.
The other thing is, we
don't rely on t-shirt sizes.
You can buy slots in a
number of granularities,
and that's really,
really powerful.
The second part I
should say is, a lot
of features come with slots.
We don't have a
special type of slots
that you have to
purchase in order
to get materialized views.
We don't have a
special type of slot
you need to purchase in order to
buy advanced security features
or customer master encryption
keys-- like time travel,
like DDoS protection
that we provide.
All of that is
included in slots.
We also do with things
like batch ingest, which
actually doesn't consume
your slot capacity.
It doesn't contend
with your queries.
It comes from somewhere else.
So you really don't pay
for batch ingest, at all.
And we also do a lot of
background processes--
like automatically
clustering-- that we
don't charge for at all.
So it's something that we
provide to you as a service
to make sure that your queries
are running exceptionally well,
and we don't charge you for it.
And of course, the
industry-best four nines of SLA
just comes with any slot.
You don't have to
pay extra for it.
I should also mention that
all of these properties you
get with bytes processed
model, as well.
And finally, because
we are serverless--
because we're not bound
to virtual machines--
we get to provide some really
interesting benefits to you.
Our architecture is very
unique in that sense.
So, the first one is, we
can provision capacity
almost instantly.
We don't have virtual machines
to spin up a provision for you.
We don't need to move data
into your virtual machine
to get performance.
It's just serverless.
It just lives there.
So for us, scaling is
just a number change.
The other thing is, of
course, the virtual machine
doesn't have to be
a pre-warned, data
doesn't need to be moved
into the virtual machine,
so you get optimal
performance immediately.
And the final bit that's a
little bit hard to capture,
but it's really, really
important for real life
use cases--
whenever you
increase capacity, it
impacts your queries
in flight immediately.
So if you have a query
that's running inside
of your environment and you
need to accelerate that query,
adding more capacity
will do that immediately.
You don't have to undo the
query, cancel the query,
and start a new one.
Queries in flight benefit
from capacity changes.
Fantastic.
One last comment on the
different commitment types.
I want to make it
really, really clear.
So, we have three commitment
types-- flex slots, monthly,
and annual.
So think about what
is the proper use
case for how to combine these.
You don't have to use
only one of those types.
It's just slots, again.
And the difference is the length
of the commitment and price.
So you can think about
it workload by workload.
You can have steady state
monthly or annual commitments
there that are used 24/7.
And you get a lower
price for them.
And then you can use
flex slots to have
kind of this first edition
capacity to the steady state
that is used for seconds,
minutes, hours, or potentially
days.
So you can combine these
two, and that becomes really,
really powerful.
I'm really delighted to
announce that, today, we're
offering 100 slots pricing.
So before today,
you had to commit
to 500 slots, which,
admittedly, is quite a lot
for a number of our customers.
So with a monthly contract,
500 slots was $10,000 a month.
So a lot of our
customers really wanted
to start using slots pricing,
but they wanted a lower price
point.
So we're introducing 100 slots.
What that means is,
on a monthly contract,
it's $2,000 per month.
On an annual contract,
it's $1,700 per month.
And on a flex contract,
it's just $4 per hour.
So you could purchase 100 slots,
cancel them after one hour,
and you only pay $4.
So it's really
inexpensive, and I'm
hoping that a lot of our
customers embrace this model.
We're continuing to expand our
administration functionality
in many different ways.
So Admin Panel UI is
one of those investments
that we're making.
It's on the the
road map, and we're
hoping to make it available
in the next few months.
Essentially what the
Administration Panel UI does,
it's a BigQuery native
monitoring and administration
platform.
It allows you to
chart how are you
using BigQuery in real time.
So it's going to allow you
to monitor slots, resources,
queries, jobs, users,
and so on and so forth.
You'll also be able to do this
in real time and historically--
going back 30 days or more--
which means that you can
zoom in and zoom out,
depending on the use case.
For the real time
use case, you can
identify whether somebody
in your organization
is using too much and
perform root cause analysis
in that way.
Whereas if you zoom
out historically,
you'll be able to decide whether
you need more capacity or less
capacity based on your
various usage patterns.
The next set of features
that we've recently launched
is information schema views.
Now, a number of these
views are already available.
Some of them are
general availability.
And what these views allow
you to do is, in real time
and historically, again, you
can see everything that's
going on inside of BigQuery.
So today we have available
jobs and reservations we use.
We're going to be soon
launching streaming views.
So if you're streaming
data into BigQuery,
you can see what's happening
there-- error rates,
bytes ingested,
things like that.
We're also going to
provide storage views.
So you can see how much data
is stored in each your column,
each of your petition,
each of your table,
and how it's being used.
And eventually, we're
going to actually
get into permissions, as well.
So some of the benefits
of information schema
that we provide--
well, for one, it's just
automatically managed by us.
It's the data that
we provide for you.
And we don't charge
you for the storage.
So that's really nice.
It's just there.
and you can start using it.
It's live, right?
So this is consistent sub-second
latency of information
that's provided to you.
It's also historical.
So we get up to six months
of historical information
in these tables,
automatically free of charge.
The other benefit is,
for larger organizations
that have lots and
lots of projects,
we provide you an
organization-wide view.
So you don't have to
query every single project
to figure out what's going on.
You can query
information schema tables
for your entire organization.
So there's lots of really
interesting use cases
that you can leverage
these tables with.
Fast forward a few
months, and 23andMeow has
been really, really successful.
But we've decided to
launch some new features.
Because we have
been capturing sound
for a long time using our
microphone on these collars,
we started developing
machine learning
models that help us understand
what the cat is actually
saying.
And then we've developed
a two-way Language
API that allows us
to understand cats,
but also to communicate back.
So it will actually translate
human English language--
only English is
supported, for now--
into cat meows and purrs.
So it allows us to communicate
directly with the cat.
This is a fantastic
feature, and it immediately
propelled us to become
a global phenomena.
We have, today, a billion
daily active cats.
And we're a multinational
organization.
We operate in 145 countries.
It's just amazing success
that we've experienced so far.
But we've grown so fast.
And we are a larger
organization, now.
But we're still using
BigQuery is the same core
of our technology.
So how do we obtain
more control?
What kinds of problems are
we facing as a billion daily
active cat organization?
So, for one, is we
really care about price.
We're about to go
IPO, so we need
to get our finances in order.
So we need to control the cost.
We need to control the cost of
the organization as a whole,
and we need to control
per-organization
all the way down to
individual users.
We also have some
really critical SLAs.
We actually run the machine
learning models often right
in BigQuery.
So those are very
important workflows
that we have, and
we need to make sure
that those get the
right resources
and they finish in the
right amounts of time.
So that's critical for us
to have workload management
capabilities.
And the third one
is cost attribution.
Again, we should be able to
trace every single action
that's happening in our
environment, down to the user
that has caused that action,
so that we can attribute costs.
So these are all very much
enterprise-grade billion
daily active cat problems
that we're facing.
So to support
these use cases, we
launched BigQuery Reservations.
This is a general
availability platform
for workflow management and cost
management inside of BigQuery.
BigQuery Reservations
today enables
you to purchase slot commitments
in seconds-- again, monthly,
annual, and flex types.
Then you can take that capacity,
and you can compartmentalize.
You can isolate and partition
it into individual departments
or teams or sets of users.
So if you have x
amount of capacity,
you want to give the individual
use cases their isolated pools.
So we allow you to do that.
And finally, it allows you
to share any unused capacity
across your organization.
So in the periods when
there's not a lot going on,
that capacity is not wasted.
It's available for the
rest of your organization
to be used seamlessly
and automatically.
So let's think about
a typical use case--
so how reservations
are used in practice.
So let's say we've figured
out that 1,000 slots is what
we need in terms of capacity.
And we said that
500 of those slots
are going to be our
steady state slots,
and we can lock them in
on a very inexpensive
annual contract.
And then 500 slots are
going to be flex slots,
simply because maybe we
want to have more or less.
We're not entirely sure.
So we do want that flexibility.
But in total, we
have 1,000 slots.
That's our capacity
for data processing.
A slot is a slot.
Step number two, we're going
to take those 1,000 slots
and we have three
different business units.
We have the team that
manages Pheromones API.
We have a team that
manages the Languages API.
And we have a team that
manages BI, all the dashboard.
That's three separate teams
within our organization.
And the pheromones
is, of course,
where we make all of our money.
So we're going to
give them 500 slots.
The languages team
is really important,
but it's a newer feature.
So we would give them 300 slots.
And then BI is going
to get 200 slots.
So we've partitioned
these workloads
into these departments.
And finally, the
third step is, we
assigned all the relevant
projects to these reservations.
And off we go.
That's all we have to
do-- set and forget.
Here's a new
feature that's going
to help even further with
this type of use case.
BigQuery Slots Autoscaling
is coming soon.
What BigQuery Slots
Autoscaling does
is it automatically provisions
and deprovisions capacity
for you, based on how
you're using our platform.
So it's really, really
advanced functionality.
So again, because we're not
running on virtual machines,
because we are serverless,
we're able to give you a lot
of benefits that a traditional
virtual machine-based data
warehouse cannot.
For one is we had a
zero second warm-up.
The moment you get your
capacity provisioned,
your capacity is at
100% performance.
There's no such thing as
hydrating your local disk
to make sure that
performance is optimal.
Second, as I already mentioned,
whenever you increase capacity,
your queries in flight take
advantage of that immediately.
The third is, again, because
we're not running local disk,
because we're not
relying on local storage,
there are no
unexpected behaviors,
like performance clips when the
local storage goes away or gets
saturated.
We don't rely on local storage.
We have true separation
of storage and compute.
And finally, we express
this in our SLA.
We're immune to downtime for
individual nodes, all the way
to large portions
of our data center.
And that's why we're able to
provide four nines of the SLA.
So let's talk about Slots
Autoscaling a little bit more.
So all we're doing here is we're
adding one additional variable
to the Reservations
configuration.
It's called max
autoscaling limit.
So let's walk
through this example.
So what we did is, for the
pheromones reservation,
we set the autoscaling
limit to be 300.
And for the BI reservation,
we set the autoscaling limit
to be 1,000.
And so we did this
per reservation.
That's where this
configuration lives.
But we didn't enable this
on the language reservation.
And so what happens is,
whenever the pheromones
reservation needs
more than 500 slots,
it will try to get that 500
slots from across the rest
of the organization.
It will try to see if the
languages reservation has
idle capacity or if BI
reservation has idle capacity.
And then it's
going to say, well,
I still need more
capacity than that
because I have a lot of
data processing to do.
And only then will reservations
autoscale or kick in.
Only then we will
increase our capacity
by 300 slots,
which is fantastic.
So the only way
auto-scaling and kicks
in is if the entire
organization is saturated
and there are no
idle slots to be had.
And then, if the capacity
is no longer necessary,
we will automatically
downscale your reservation.
So pheromones will go from
500 slots to 800 slots
and down, whereas BI will
go from 200 to 1,200 slots
and down.
Now, something I
should mention is
that, the current
version of autoscaling
that we're working
on is binary, which
means that we will only
increase to the maximum amount
or back to the minimum amount.
So in this example, the
pheromones reservation
will only be at size
500 or size 800.
There's no intermediate state.
And of course,
eventually we will
have all these advanced
autoscaling modes, as well.
So how does autoscaling work
with steady state capacity?
Well, really, you
think about it--
you can purchase monthly
annual flex commitments
and keep them as steady state
capacity that is always there,
that is guaranteed for you.
And then you can
turn on autoscaling
on top of that to provide
burst, and it's managed for you.
Autoscaling only kicks
in when necessary.
How do you pay for it?
Well, what we do is we
purchase flex slots for you.
So autoscaling underneath
the hood uses flex slots.
And so you play the
flex slots rates.
Now, here's a really,
really advanced capability
that autoscaling provides
for you, starting from zero.
This is called the "auto-pause"
or "auto-start" use case.
So in this example, we
actually have zero commitments.
We've purchased zero slots,
and all of our reservations
are sized to be zero, which
means that there's not
a single slot purchased
or provisioned
and you pay us nothing in
terms of analytic capability.
But we set autoscaling
for each reservation.
So pheromones,
language, BI, they all
have autoscaling
with limits set.
In this mode, whenever a query
comes into the environment,
we will immediately
scale the reservation
to its maximum limit, and the
query will execute immediately.
And then, on the opposite
side, whenever your reservation
is idle, we will
diminish it back to zero.
So this is essentially
auto-pause, auto-start.
Your BigQuery
environment will only
operate when you're
running queries,
and it will shut
down when you queries
are not running,
which will enable you
to save a good amount of money.
So I've talked about
a number of features
that enable you to
kind of traverse
the gradient of growth--
from a tiny little
start up, or just trying
to go to market quickly, to
a midsize organization, all
the way to a
multinational organization
with complex requirements and
complex needs and reporting
and so on and so forth.
So let's kind of
summarize everything
that we've talked about.
So on the pricing front,
we have flex slots
that went GA at the of June.
We recently launched 100 slots.
So now you can purchase capacity
for as little as $2,000 a month
with a monthly
contract, or $4 per hour
with the flex contract.
And the other thing we
talked about quite a bit
is the fact that we
share idle capacity
across your environment.
It doesn't go to waste.
The second point is workload
management capability.
So once you have
this capacity, how
do you actually break it up into
your department's workloads?
Well, Reservations is a powerful
platform that enables that,
and it's GA.
But we recently announced
Slots Autoscaling
with that additional
level of automation
that enables you to
scale up and down
and only pay for
what you consume.
And finally, we talked
about Admin Panel,
which is the visual UI
that we will provide
to help you monitor
and perform root cause
analysis on your environment.
And finally, intelligence--
higher level data
and logic it will provide
to you that will help you
drive your decision making.
So of course, information
schema is a project
that will have a
series of views that
will enable you to get data
and slot recommendations-- just
a first step in this advanced
intelligence that will tell you
exactly what's going
on in the environment
and will recommend to
you further action.
Now, actual administration
and performance
is just one part of the story.
Of course, as an
administrator, oftentimes, you
care about performance.
We'll continue to
invest in this area.
Throughout the years we've
always BigQuery faster, faster,
faster, and faster.
So just from the beginning
of this year, alone--
from January 1--
we look at the industry
standard TPC-DS benchmarks,
and we measure our
performance improvements
to be anywhere from 20% to 30%.
And the way you get
this benefit is just
the next time you run
a query, you will just
get better performance.
We perform these optimizations
for you on the background.
We roll out code without
disturbing your environment.
You just get these benefits,
and you get these benefits
without any additional cost.
So this is a trend that we have.
Every few months we add
some better performance
optimizations.
Your queries just
become faster and faster
and faster and faster.
And this trend will
continue in the future.
So we talked about
this quite a bit.
When you're starting
out, you really
want the easiest
path to go to market.
You don't want to
worry about things.
And so our serverless capability
enables you to do that.
There's nothing to set up.
You only pay for what you
consume, and off you go.
But as you grow, you care
more about different things.
You care more about
control and predictability.
So we've built out a series
of capabilities that enable
you to take advantage of that.
But the key is that all of
these things are optional.
You only need to use
Admin Panel if you
care about predictability
and control
and you're a certain size.
So please be mindful
of that, because we
have a lot of customers
that are on the larger side,
but we have lots and
lots of customers
that are on the free tier or
have very, very little data
inside of BigQuery.
And that's perfectly OK.
BigQuery is built for everyone.
We recently talked
about trial slots.
So this is a promotion
for new BigQuery customers
that enables you to
get 95% off of slots.
So essentially, you
can buy 500 slots
for a duration of six
months for $500 per month.
This is 1/20th of the cost
of a monthly contract.
So it's just $1
per slot per month.
Of course, it's just slots,
so you can combine them
with other types of slots.
You can combine them
with other flex slots--
monthly, annually, and so forth.
And of course, it covers all of
your SQL queries that you run.
So it's a good
amount of capacity.
Now, I should be mindful to tell
you that this is a promotion,
so certain qualifications
and restrictions do apply.
So finally, I want to
open the floor to everyone
to think about the
next 10x use case
for our tiny little
startup, 23andMeow.
There's lots of things
that cats can do,
and we're open to collaboration.
We're open to more ideas.
So send me some of your ideas
on Twitter to the Tino team.
And I really
appreciate all the time
that you spent listening to me.
Thank you so much.